hey guys welcome back to another video
and today we're going to be talking
about the two new videos that were kind
of been surfacing around Reddit and
YouTube for the past like 24 hours or so
so let's get right into that so the
videos that have been surfacing are
basically minute and a half or thirty
second visit to 30 second videos roughly
of new emotes that all these characters
are getting so I will show you both of
them right now but before we get into
that I just want to say thank you all
for the great love and support on these
past couple videos they're really
helping me out and if you have any ideas
on videos you want me to do any
suggestions please put them down in the
comments below and I will gladly look
into them because I always want to give
back to you guys and make you be a part
of this channel so once again if you
have any ideas about any type of video
you want me to discuss please put that
in the comments and I will hopefully get
to that but anyway guys let's get right
into these two videos so I'll see you
when they're done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
boy
so that was really cool I really did
like the new emotes that the Centurion
the shinobi are getting like the flappy
bird kind of emo I just want to say a
quick shot of those two dice box gaming
for the 12 for the character for the old
character emotes and then for the new
characters I want to thank the Koosh
Koosh Ikki Takumi on reddit for posting
that on reddit so thank you to both of
them these are really cool emotes I do
hope they're going to be into the game I
did read that I guess the conquer emote
the one where he kind of like walks his
little to flail kind of like to walk the
dog emote was I guess NPC already I
cannot confirm because I do plan on
counsel but if that's the case I don't
exactly know why PC has it but we don't
so that's kind of confusing to me anyway
guys that's going to be the end like I
said if you in the beginning if you have
any ideas that you want me to talk about
put them in the comments below and I'll
glad we talked about it that could be
discussion videos types of videos you
want anything and I'll gladly look into
them anyway that's going to be the end
if you want to see my last video you can
click the card in the top right a little
a icon or I'll put an annotation on the
screen where we talked about the DLC
patches or the patches for the DLC
characters for shinobi and Centurion so
you don't want to miss out on that
anyway guys I will see you all in the
next video and peace out guys have a
great rest of your day